PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Today, we are talking
about finding the right tools,
frequently asked questions,
and editing in the Cloud.
I'm Priyanka, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Choosing the right
tool for the job
is essential for getting
something done right.
And Cloud technologies
are no different.
The right tool depends on
highly individualized criteria,
like language
support, compatibility
with existing tools,
portability, and openness,
and cost.
While you might not know
every product mapping
across providers, you probably
have the foundational knowledge
to understand which
product categories are
the most relevant to you.
That's why we just published
a handy product map
showcasing similar offerings
between Google Cloud, AWS,
and Azure.
Take a look and find out
which tools work best for you.
With all those tools, there
maybe some technologies
you're not familiar with yet.
Thankfully, our editorial team
has put together this quick 101
guide on some frequently asked
questions and definitions that
can help you get started, or
brush up on some concepts.
We've just made Doc
AI generally available
to help you automate
and validate documents
to streamline your
document workflows.
Whether you're sitting on
a ton of unstructured data
or looking to reduce
your manual workload,
Doc AI is the
right tool to help.
What better way to get
started than this guide
and video from
developer advocate Anu
to show you how it works?
Cloud Shell Editor
makes it easy for you
to deploy code to the Cloud
directly from your web browser.
In this video,
developer advocate
Ryan will show you some of the
features of Cloud Shell Editor,
including integrating
Cloud code,
simplifying Kubernetes
and Cloud-run development
workflows.
Check it out and stay
tuned for more videos
around how to use it.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment, or tweet us.
We will see you in the Cloud.